i thought it was really sweet moment in
the book you know you say my last
conversation with john we sat and talked
about baking bread and i went oh gosh
that's so beautiful because that's
almost like a full circle kind of thing
they spoke about baking like baking
bread it feeds you it's it warms the
house when you bake bread yeah it was
very special to me that we reached that
point actually because you know you'd
had the whole horrible thing of the
group breaking up i think we just
realized come on guys we love each other
what are we doing we're messing around
and
i ring john and i was making bread and
got quite good at it you know so when i
heard john was doing it it was great we
could just talk about something so
ordinary
there's no threat
or anything it was just two guys
talking about well i don't know would
you do you leave it overnight or what do
you do you know and someone says yeah i
leave it overnight in a hot cupboard and
you'd just be chatting and it was really
nice and i was so glad that that we got
back to that relationship that we always
had you know we were kids
we'd lived in each other's pockets
for so long that it was it was great to
get back to that